I came home I was excited I had a little
bag I had a little bag it was late
though like kids were asleep everybody
was asleep okay Jasmine wants to sleep
but I thought she was she was she
thought this was grounds for a wake up
yes her first thing she was like are
those the kids initials I was like yeah
she goes it looks like a license plate
right away
I don't think it does it's a dog tag and
then she goes why would you get a dog
tag with the kids initials I swear to
God
and then I was like terrible and I was
like I was like oh I was like well
here's yours and then she was like yeah
I'm gonna open this now and I was like
yeah just open it quick and she's like
okay so she opens it I was like do you
do you like it like be honest I was like
I can take it back and she was like how
could you take it back
[Laughter]